[Music]  Lascars Ola began as a Franciscan  monastery but today is an architectural  Wonderland in the 1950s an architect  named Tomas abou C purchase laaskar Zola  and turny Italy with the intention of  turning it into his own ideal city each  work is carefully thought out and built  to represent an inner thought of tomasa  he considered this is autobiography in  stone  Oscar zullo's formed by seven theaters  representing Tomaso's notion that the  ideal life is symbolically theatrical  influenced by Delhi and Escher his  Styles a blend of surrealist  architecture and neo Mannerist elements  which can be felt in the general  unbalanced and disproportionate feel of  the place these elements are meant to  reflect Tomaso's passionate belief that  life is both mysterious and perplexing  aster Tommaso passed in 1981 his nephew  continued to work on La Scala to  complete his uncle vision allowing  Tomaso's ideal city to live on  you